[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
البرد له بدايه وشده ونهايه فبدايته مع
موسم الصفري في اول شهر اكتوبر وشدته مع
موسم الزيرك في اول يناير ونهايته مع
نهايه برد العجوز في اخر شهر مارس ونحن
الان نعيش في موسم برد بياع الخبل عباته
وهو البرد الذي يلسعنا على حين غفله من
امرنا ولهذا يسمى بل عقرب لا ادبر الدنيا
والحظ ما طاب الناس لا من طحت ما يرحمونك
لا تامن العقرب ولا تامن الداب اسهم واحد
لا رقى
في متونك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وخلال هذه الايام ينتشر الربيع بجميع
انواعه وتخرج الحشرات والزواحف والهوام
مسامه العقارب والثعابين من مخابئها
ويلسعنا النهار بشمسه وينسعنا الليل ببرده
ويلسعنا المناخ بتقلباته الجويه ولهذا
تنتشر عندنا الامراض الموسميه وهذه هي
تكاليف الحياه سئمت تكاليف الحياه ومن يعش
ثمانين حولا لا ابا لك يسامي رايت المنايا
خبط عشوائي من تصب تمده ومن تخطئ يع
مر فيحرمي
[موسيقى]